dominique desseigne bonsoir marc ange
nardi virginie desarnauts fabrice tiozzo
champion du monde wba laurent baffie et
voilà en plus il était d'accord pour que
je prenne sa place oui là parce que je
veux évidemment elle n'a pas fait de
discussions ça va il est calme cela
entre deux combats il est bien il s'est
cantonné sur le ring qui s'énerve mais
c'est les surveille la
dominique bientôt 60 ans enfin le 19
août 2004 j'aurai 60 ans et plus tôt
plutôt bien pour 60 capitaux plutôt bien
conservé on essaye malgré les épreuves
que vous avez traversé dont on va parler
vous êtes veuf de diane barrière avec
qui vous avez eu deux enfants alexandre
17 ans aujourd'hui et joy 11 ans alors
qu'ils étaient diane barrière pour nos
amis téléspectateurs qui ne la
connaîtraient pas c'est la deuxième
fortune de france est l'héritière de son
père adoptif lucien barrière et le
groupe barrière donc que vous dirigez
aujourd'hui est un fabuleux empire de de
luxe avec des casinos des palaces enfin
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'affaires 1 oui des responsabilités
mais en même temps un challenge
formidable noir
continuer l'oeuvre de la famille ou
alors quand vous rencontrez diane
barrière à l'époque vous êtes nos terres
et puis après l'accident de votre femme
dont on va parler vous devenez patron du
groupe et usufruitier du groupe que vous
pensez transmettre à vos enfants donc
vous êtes en fait là comme en région on
pourrait dire voilà pour la quatrième
génération
voilà c'est ça alors d'ailleurs
récemment vous avez pris une grande
décision c'est de fusionner le groupe
barrière avec le groupe accor vous
gardez bien sûr nos accords casino accor
casinos voient là et vous vous gardez
51% des parts mais ça donne quand même
le premier groupe de casinos en france 1
milliard d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
beaucoup d'argent
alors ce soir ce n'est pas le flamboyant
patron que nous recevons mais mais
l'homme blessé celui qui publie chez
plon un livre qui s'appelle tout pour
être heureux ou vous raconter
l'accident et les suites de l'accident
dont a été victime
votre épouse c'est un livre poignant
très bouleversant dont je conseille la
lecture à tout le monde parce que c'est
une vraie leçon de courage vous préciser
d'ailleurs par ailleurs dominique
desseigne que les droits d'auteur sont
versés à l'association un bouchon un
sourire présidée par notre ami jean
marie bigard
à la rigueur il a enfin un entrepôt à
paris dans le 19ème l'adresse va
s'afficher en battant gilles avions
pourront porter leurs bouchons à paris
voilà un local jean marie est un homme
de coeur est déjà sous l'égide de ma
femme le groupe s'est associé à
son sa fondation la collecte de bouchons
ça permet de d'acheter des fauteuils de
tétraplégique et quand on a cette triste
expérience on sait que ça casse hélas
souvent et que la sécurité sociale ne
peut pas tous remboursés et que ceux qui
n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir des moyens financiers comme
les avais ma femme se trouve en plus du
handicap dans le besoin de se racheter
un fauteuil qui a cassé donc bravo jean
marie et
c'est un homme de coeur merci
alors au lieu du livre de 1208 on sait
mais elle était jeune elle était belle a
été vibrante elle avait tout et quand on
nous voyait c'était toujours la même
phrase qui est d'ailleurs le titre de
votre livre ils ont tout pour être
heureux mais aujourd'hui quand je
repense à ça ça me flingue quoi ça me
fout les larmes aux yeux ça me flanque
je dois dire que c'est vrai que la vie
continue et elle doit continuer surtout
quand on a deux enfants fantastiques
il faut ne pas oublier est le meilleur
moyen de ne pas oublier c'est de mettre
par écrit ce que elle a vécu ce que j'ai
vécu d'abord pour mes enfants
parce que comme tous les enfants ils se
protègent et aujourd'hui quand je parle
de moments j'ai pas beaucoup d'écho
c'est normal c'est ça a été trop dur
trop trop douloureux trop cette visite
est jeune très jeune à ma petite et et
maggio il était une bébé avait
quatre ans
fils un peu plus âgés et donc ne pas
oublier c'est essentiel et puis j'ai
fait aussi ce livre pour toutes les
familles qui hélas qu on un jour dans le
malheur
pour leur dire que même quand il ya le
pire
avec de l'amour avec des amis avec des
médecins parce que
les gens autour de nous une équipe
médicale extraordinaire eh bien il ya eu
des moments de bonheur de gaieté de
bonheur différent de ce qu'est le
bonheur des autres mais des moments de
bonheur très très fort et puis
le paradoxe je l'avoué humblement mais
le cachet ne ferait pas honnête c'est
par moment elle qui me remonter et elle
me disait j'ai beaucoup de chance
j'ai un mari
j'ai ma mère j'ai un groupe magnifique
deux enfants superbe des collaborateurs
prestigieux un métier un métier
extraordinaire j'avoue l'eau j'ai
beaucoup de chance je sais pas comment
elle faisait le prononcer je pense
qu'elle voulait dire que par rapport aux
autres qui avait ça sans fortune c'était
sa chance
perdre n'est pas d'hier que six ans je
sais pas comment elle a tenu et je crois
qu'un jour elle a voulu arrêter et qu'
elle s'est en allé sur la pointe des
pieds parce qu'elle pensait que ça avait
trop duré on va raconter d'histoires
c'est un dimanche de juillet 1995 votre
épouse donc diane barrière vient de
saint tropez à la baule dans un petit
avion et l'avion s'écrase dans un champ
le pilote et le co pilote sont morts et
votre femme est sorti des flammes in
extremis d'ailleurs on doit dire état
très grave d'abord on l'emmène à
l'hôpital de la roche sur yon puis
ensuite à l'hôpital de bordeaux et là
vous vous refusez de la laisser vous
refusez de vous coucher vous dites je
vais rester là et puis j'attendrai toute
ma vie s'il le faut oui parce que
quand ça vous tombe sur le dos elle
était dans le coma donc
j'étais seul avec ma lucidité
on se dit mais c'est pas vrai
ce cauchemar et puis j'ai appris une
grande chose
c'est que dans des épreuves pareil il
faut vivre au jour le jour et si on se
projette on meurt donc j'avais un but
dans cette attente la mort
est là et et perpétuelle pendant 6 ans
j'étais
il n'y a pas un jour où je ne tremblait
pas et pas un jour je me disais pas ça
devait arriver quand je suis au gros
c'est arrivé quand je suis en voyage et
d'ailleurs c'est arrivé j'étais en
voyage donc le portable pour moi était
une souffrance terrible parce que le
portable je vais pas qu'il sonne et
auditionné
c'était la crainte et
je crois qu'il fallait pas se révolter
elle ne s'est jamais révoltée elle a
toujours cru au karma je crois qu'elle a
accentué cette croyance et elle me
disait ça m'aide à accepter et
elle disait je paye sans doute une vie
antérieure les choses de mal que j'ai
fait une vie terrible je lis pourquoi tu
dis ça elle veut dit ça m'aide et cette
acceptation elle nous l'a propulsé la
insuffler à ses amis et elle a voulu se
battre donc là évidemment le diagnostic
tombe poumon
calcinées les alvéoles empli de fumée
brûlures au troisième degré
les bras et les jambes les côtés le
bassin cassé alors comme vous dites dans
votre livre c'est des choses qui prises
séparément sont pas ultra grave mais
quand c'est tout en même temps
effectivement ça prend des proportions
absolument terrible et quand vous pouvez
enfin la voir à l'hôpital de bordeaux a
le visage qui a doublé de volume et vous
parlez on va on dirait une statue de
cire oui parce que
quand on a chaque pareil le visage enfle
les bandelettes partout la fixité
puisque le coma après
en tubes et après l'attaqué au enfin
tout une superposition de drame mais à
mes
fans des merveilleux médecin que j'ai
eus gérard saillant bien connu des
sportifs
m'avait dit un jour me voyant
complètement défait il m'a dit tu sais
dominique l'être humain s'adapte à tous
j'avoue au début je me dis mais
qu'est ce que gérard me raconte tu
déconnes et quelques années plus tard
sur la fin diane m'a dit me voyant
complètement voix c'est parce que moi
les médecins me disais la vérité et elle
m'a dit tu sais chérie on s'adapte à
tous donc là aussi c'est un message à
faire passer et je voulais faire une
incidence sur le drame de
de madrid aujourd'hui dès que j'ai connu
ce drame j'ai été très attristée pour
les 200 morts mais ma pensée l'étaler
pour les familles et pour les handicapés
parce que je sais ça et si mon livre
peut les aider à se dire que dans
l'ouverture récente d'un drame qui sera
un drame familial un drame des amis si
ils peuvent à la lecture de mon livre se
dire que malgré tout il ya du bonheur
malgré tout y aura des moments de rire
malgré tout y aura des moments
où on est heureux d'être dans la vie je
crois que je leur ai rendu service
merci
alors
à partir de lundi de scènes nous vous
raconter tout c'est toutes ces
péripéties le médecin qui vous appelle
un jour en vous disant est là
42.7 de fièvre c'est absolument
impossible vous dites tous tous des
tracas 42.7 plus grave on parle d'un
moment d'amputation des jambes alors là
vous vous dites je rentre chez moi je me
mets la tête sur l'oreiller j'enfonce ma
tête dans le polochon je mords le
polochon avec mes dents je me met à
hurler comme un chien je suis seul et
toutes ces épreuves voulait passer tout
seul épreuve incroyable après bon on lui
coupe pas les gens mais personne pense à
vous le dire dont vous vivez comme ça je
vis la journée que je suis une journée
en pensant qu'on va l'amputer ensuite
bien plus grave encore compte tenu des
brûlures au visage les médecins se
disent mais on pourra jamais faire de la
chirurgie réparatrice parce que c'est
trop brûlé on parle d'un masque dit nous
avons démasqué vous imaginez un moment
que votre femme être obligé de porter un
masque de sa vie pour agir mais le sport
et le sport
vous pourrez beaucoup oui est ce que
vous êtes vous défoncer dans le jogging
qu'est ce qui vous est à retenir le
sport m'a beaucoup aidé et d'ailleurs je
pense que si je n'avais pas été sportif
j'aurais pu devenir fou parce que je
suis d'un tempérament de nature
angoissée j'y peux rien c'est comme ça
et
quand sans arrêt on est dans l' angoisse
de dire quand ça ça peut arriver à tout
moment c'est dur de vivre longtemps
comme ça et
j'avoue que
j'avais moins de force qu'elle
est que je ne sais pas comment elle a pu
se mettre dans cette vie et je voulais
insister sur un point qui est
extraordinaire c'est grand moment de
bonheur elle les avait bien sûr en
famille mais les avais dans le travail
oui et c'était phénoménal de la voir
travailler alors que la réinsertion des
handicapés par le travail jantes et
moins conscient mais aujourd'hui c'est
primordial je les ai vus se sublimer
dans le travail dans son fauteuil
il fallait positionner les mains parce
que en plus à laver la moelle n'était
pas
coupée ce qui veut dire que l avaient
toutes les douleurs
et
était en souffrance sans arrêt si
morphine par jour et dans le travail
tout d'un coup c'était une autre diane
et avec un cerveau très agile toujours
oui les et handicapés moteurs notamment
quand elle a toujours été extrêmement
intelligente extrêmement brillante et
les handicapés
qu'on pense et l'agilité du cerveau est
encore plus grande d'ailleurs jeu par
moments surtout au début quand pendant
des mois ne pouvait pas parler
puisqu'elle était dans le coma
et quand la pio des lions ne faut
réapprendre à parler et nous avions un
code quand j'ai quand elle est revenue à
elle après plusieurs mois il y avait
les paupières les clignements d'yeux et
on s'était donné un code et il y avait
les claquements de langue et quand tu es
très fatigué ne pouvait pas claquer la
langue c'était elle sortait la langue et
on utilisait aussi un alphabet où on
essayait de recomposer les messages
qu'elle voulait me faire passer et moi
j'étais paniqué et a toujours mais un
gars très perçante ribot battre et
c'était une femme forte et je sentais
que par moment elle se disait mais il
est comme mon mari mais les cons bon
sens alors et maintenant je m'en
souviens avec c'est un bon moment
presque un terrible c'est que vous
effectivement vous établissez avec elle
à un contact à travers les battements de
paupières mais comme elle avait été
brûlée elle pouvait pas fermer
complètement les yeux ça corner était
atteinte et elle risquait de devenir
aveugle selon l'udc ou les paupières et
pour mu c'est terrible parce que le seul
moyen que vous aviez de communiquer avec
elle un certaine période oui
paupières cours débuteront avec des
sparadraps et
quand il n'y avait pas la parole à cause
de la ventilation ou d'un trop grande
faiblesse le contact c'était les yeux
surtout son regard perçant puis on on se
connaissait tellement et tout d'un coup
je perdais tout contact avec la vie
puisqu'il y avait l'immobilité et puis
ce regard perçant ce beau regard bleu
vert qui disparaissait et et c'est pour
ça que j'ai je dis l'oeil et aidant à
moitié dans la tombe et c'était terrible
c'est comme dire oui et alors elle vous
parle à un moment aussi un soir vous
êtes vous êtes et les accompagnez vos
enfants en vacances au ski et elle vous
appelle sur le portable et vous entendez
un vous dites un son rauque venus du
fond de l'être c'est-à-dire qu'elle dit
votre surnom je crois qu'on peut dire
parce que vous le dites elle vous
appelez bouchonne
sinon tout cela vous informer vous
entendez ce nom prononcé de très loin
trader âgé et c'était la première fois
après
des mois et des mois de silence et tout
d'un coup un son un petit sont à cause
de la traquer au et alors là j'ai pris
ça
comme une droite en plein en plein
visage une émotion énorme et un choc un
choc de bonheur mais on accuse le coup
et vous avez été exemplaire parce que à
cause de la trachéotomie qu'on avait dû
lui faire parce que vous la nourrice et
à la petite cuillère et pendant des mois
et neuf mois voilà et vous apprenez l'
usage de ce qu'on appelle la nouille moi
je savais pas que ça existait ça c'est
un tube qu'on me parle à traquer qui a
traqué aussi un trou ici ou ici une fois
qu'on a un tube est trop longtemps
on est obligés d'enlever le tube et ont
fait une trachéo et là il ya tout un
système où on ventile et
sas obstrue souvent la nourriture fait
ce qu'on appelle des fausses routes et
on s'étouffe donc il n'ya pas de cours
pour ça donc
quand vous prenez votre flamme à la
maison parce qu'il faut rentrer dans la
vie il faut tenter le coup
et kit médical si personne enfin mais
quand il ya un pépin et que vous êtes
seul vous qui vous y coller oui et puis
on a peur on a peur d'eux dans ces
moments là vous n'avez jamais eu envie
de jeu pas de vous [ __ ] en l'air de
2,10 g prête j'ai pensé mais attendez
la femme et enfants des responsabilités
mais par moments je me dis mais
c'est un cauchemar pour elle et puis je
me dis bats toi et là aussi
la gagne la gagnes tu t'accroches
et aujourd'hui
je lui dis merci pour le bel exemple
qu'elle m'a montré et
j'espère qu'avec ce livre mes enfants
comprendront mieux ce qu'était leur mère
et qu' ils en sortiront grandis même si
aujourd'hui
on fait ce qu'on peut mais c'est pas
simple alors un jour diane finit par
rentrer à la maison ne fallait pas bien
donc si piqûre de morphine par jour elle
refuse les miroirs évidemment et un jour
elle se voit dans un verre dépoli
et là elle a une phrase qui m'a fait
très mal
parce qu' elle étai jusqu'au bout
coquette elle était femme elle était
jusqu'au bout malgré le pire elle ne
descendait jamais
dîner quand elle pouvait descendre
c'était hélas pas tout le temps sans est
sans se faire
vraiment le petit foulard pour cacher la
traque et au la boucle d'oreille pour
plaire au mari
pouvait peut-être pas parler par moments
mais elle descendait et puis
tout d'un coup
on se trouvent dans des situations
dramatiques
ça se passe pas bien pendant
le dîner
sent soudain mal et il faut il faut
improviser il faut rester il faut rester
auprès d'elle faux faux et
oui c'est une
c'est une leçon de vie il faut mais on
peut pas il faut pas se révolter alors
le plus pathétique pour moi c'est qu'à
un moment elle vous dit qu'elle veut
avoir un autre enfant un troisième
enfant et une vie trop bien sûr et là
c'est terrible parce que vous j'ai eu 2
2 moment où
j'ai dû mentir
honteusement
1 le jour où elle revient de garches et
j'ai dû fuir tout adapté dans la maison
l arène rentrer dans sa salle de bains
toujours poussé dans un étage et tout
d'un coup elle voit qu'il n'ya pas de
toilettes
qui a un trou pour la douche juste un
lavabo
et lâchant que dans le regard que je
suis à la limite en train de me faire
engueuler et que je peux pas lui dire
que et médecins m'ont dit que c'était
pas la peine qu'il fallait que je fasse
de l'adapter ouais parce que quand on
lie à sedan ce drame on vous dit tout
sur le fauteuil est
dur dur et
j'ai bien j'ai dû j'ai dû
dire bah oui les travaux là il ya eu il
ya eu un loupé
on fait avec donc
j'ai menti et puis il ya eu d'autres
situations où j'étais dans quand on lui
dit qu'elle veut un enfant voulu vous
faites quoi vous dites alors
pour moi je pouvais pas lui dire
c'est inconcevable a d'abord tu peut en
mourir de t'arrivera pas en avoir
3 c'est pas un cadeau pour le petit
parce que bon donc il faut gagner du
temps
pour cesser ce que je sais c'est que
j'ai réagi oui et j'ai joué ce qu'on
appelle jouer la montre donc j'ai dit
pourquoi pas la faune de la forêt
fondation in vitro on va voir
mais les deux autres vont être jaloux
est ce qui est ya pensé j'ai joué la
montre et
le temps a dû faire les choses c'était
d'autant plus douloureux que avant
qu'elles soient handicapés j'en voulais
un troisième et n était pas très chaude
et puis tout d'un coup peuvent ses
revenus
bon j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu je crois
que j'ai trouvé les mots le temps ça
apaisé or après elle veut tenter un
traitement aux usa ali val rencontre
d'ailleurs superman christopher reeve
messi et et alors elle c'était le bruit
donc à l'état les voir christophe riffs
moi j'étais à new york mais elle y est
allée elle revient et là encore son côté
formidable dire j'ai beaucoup de chance
parce qu'il faut le dire j'ai beaucoup
de chance hein
parce que
dans son état si elle n'avait pas eu les
moyens de se payer
tout le staff autour elle serait morte
depuis longtemps ouais onu et six ans ça
aurait fait un nom
ça il n'ya pas y'a pas photo et
et elle était toujours avec
son j'ai beaucoup de chance elle me dit
christopher reeves est beaucoup plus
mieux que moi chérie beaucoup mieux bon
je dis pourquoi elle me dit 'il est
sanglé sont dans son fauteuil
moi j'arrive à tenir bon et pas c'était
bien elle elle penser aux autres avant
de penser à elle voilà malheureusement
le traitement ne nous réussit pas elle a
été tellement dans le coma j'ai dit
cette fois aux enfants que maman allait
mourir sur le conseil des médecins pour
les préparer pour les préparer et
la dernière fois où elle s'en est sortie
ça a était sur la corde raide pendant
quinze jours et moi je m'étais dit allez
on va se battre donc j'ai faits
enregistrés par les enfants des mots
d'amour c'était moment accroche-toi
anthem moment on a besoin de toi moment
ne nous quitte pas et j'avais donc en
real ou rld
la voir tous les jours et je passais ma
cassette
en me disant ce que dans l'au delà on va
toujours dire ce qui était revenu qu'on
entendait bon et après elle s'en est
sortie cette fois là et
je lui parler de ça il m'a dit j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir entendu les enfants
qui me parlait et elle disait avec
fierté et coquetterie
j'ai donné la vie à mes enfants ils me
l'ont rendu et ça je trouve que les fier
c'est magnifique
ça s'appelle tu pour être heureux
estaing pas cassé et s'est invité chez
plon
or évidemment la question c'est pourquoi
cet accident alors quand on quand on lit
votre livre on apprend d'abord que le
plein de petit avion qui allait de saint
tropez à la baule le plan n'était pas
fait il ya eu des erreurs de pilotage et
cette petite compagnie n'avait pas
d'autorisation pour transporter du
public alors la question c'est comment
quelqu'un comme elle qui est quand même
les moyens qui passe son temps à voyager
d'un côté à l'autre de la france parce
que le groupe barrière s'est partout
comment quelqu'un comme elle peut monter
dans un avion c'est celle que nous
avions pris avec
mes enfants toute la famille cet avion
qui était très bien très bonne qualité
d'avion ça c'était parfaitement passé
ouais et ensuite c'était une compagnie
qui était
régionale recommandé par la chambre de
commerce
ce qui veut dire que bon
première expérience
superbement bien passé donc pourquoi pas
et donc voilà et puis
est arrivé
et ce drame c'était en fin de compte du
transport illicite et la gendarmerie
qu'avait dressé un procès-verbal
antérieurement notant que c'était du
transport illicite ça n'avait pas suivi
ce qui veut dire que double drame quand
elle est revenue
après de longs mois on est à d'essayer
de comprendre le pourquoi elle m'a dit
je veux savoir je veux que tu me tues tu
fasses qu'il faut et nous attendons une
réponse depuis sept ans vous même vous
qui êtes un homme important influence
vous arrivez pas obtenir une heure on
est en procédure
alors j'imagine ce que nous faisons
comme patrick harris how police ce
combat 1 je le fais pour ma femme parce
qu'elle m'a demandé de le faire mais je
le fais aussi pour que le transport
illicite en france ne soit plus accepter
ses programmes
alors celui de seine
avant nous séparer je vais vous demander
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
j'ai beaucoup prié dieu pendant cette
épreuve j'avais une sainte vierge en
face de moi que vous m'avez offert un
ami et je dois dire que a pas un certain
moment bout de plusieurs années chaque
fois que je priais bas c'était pire
alors je crois toujours en dieu mais il
ya un moment j'ai arrêté de
de prier dieu ouais et puis maintenant
quand ça va pas
je l'appelle je me dis que la
connaissant comme elle et elle doit être
pas loin du bon dieu et je lui dis bah
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu avec mes
faiblesses parce que je n'ai pas été
parfait qui est parfait mais je les fais
avec mon coeur c'était normal c'est avec
mon courage mais j'ai quand on sait avec
son coeur fait c'est facile mais et
jeudi je l'appelle et je lui dis si tu
pouvais me donner un petit coup de main
pour moi et les enfants ça me ferait
plaisir voilà
merci d'avoir égalé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu